chers collègues en 2040 un tiers de la
population aura plus de 60 ans mes chers
collègues 2040 c'est demain la question
du vieillissement de la population ne
peut être contournée il faut l'assumer
dès maintenant il faut garantir le
financement des retraites le
gouvernement us de péripéties de
péripéties verbal de métaphores et
d'autres méthodes pour ne pas nommer sa
volonté envisager d'établir un âge deck
libre revient en réalité à décaler l'âge
de départ à la retraite nous le savons
tous ici sur ces bancs à tous de décote
et de surcote pour ceux partant avant ou
après l'âge d'équilibré prévu celui-ci
nul doute augmentera de façon
automatique en fonction de
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
aussi le texte prévoit l'équipe qui
coûte à 2025
je crains ici d'ici là une baisse des
pensions pour arriver à cet objectif
le projet de loi organique suscite à cet
égard bien des interrogations et doit
attirer notre attention et notre
vigilance car nous ne connaissons pas
toutes les conséquences de votre réforme
et nous le découvrons au fil des
discussions
mes chers collègues sont hermine un
tiers deux ordonnances
aucun vote en commission peut-être
peut-être aucun vote en séance compte
tenu du calendrier de la préparation
cette façon de faire est contraire à
l'esprit démocratique et ne respecte pas
le parlement les délais accordés aux
députés la restriction de leurs votes
justifie un rejet préalable de ces
textes de surcroît l'étude d'impact ne
respecte pas les obligations de la loi
organique 2009 403 cette étude d'impact
elle est à complète et un sincère elle
viole cette loi organique qui date de
2009 le groupe l'est républicain saisira
bien entendu le conseil constitutionnel
sur ce sujet qui à lui seul justifie un
rejet de ses textes
mes chers collègues face à cette
situation qu'on ne peut que déplorer
je vous invite à voter la motion de
rejet que nous avons déposés et au delà
de vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés
mes chers collègues je ne peut
qu'attirer l'attention
du gouvernement messieurs les ministres
on ne peut qu être légitimement à quai
sur votre réforme
entendez les oppositions entendez cette
france qui gronde
entendez cette france qui ne veut pas de
cette réforme décalé l'examen de ce
texte pour nous permettre d'aboutir à
une réforme construite et financée
merci cher collègue monsieur deux
ministres merci président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
stéphane bierry j'écoutais votre
intervention avec intérêt et sur le fond
nous sommes ici pour débattre de votre
motion de rejet sur le projet de loi
organique projet de loi organique qui
porte en son sein comme principale
mesure la définition de l' équilibre
mais aussi la volonté de rassurer les
français sur la valeur du point et ces
éléments qui d'ailleurs ont pu être
débattu en commission spéciale puisque
vous en souvenez c'est le texte que nous
avons pu examiner entièrement la
mercredi le dernier joueur de cette
commission spéciale sur le fond moi je
crois répond à une partie des
interrogations que vous avez évoquées
même si je lis sur votre visage
le fait que vous ne partagez pas ma
lecture alors pour être très clair la
révision de la loi organique
elle est indispensable pour mener à bien
la réforme c'est pour ça qu'il ya ce
projet de loi organique à côté de ce
projet de loi ordinaire
elle est indispensable pour donner au
parlement et sur le fond je crois que
vous appelez de vos voeux une vision
complète du système est intégré au chant
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale les aspects notamment des
régimes complémentaires de retraite
c'est en soi un progrès et une demande
d'ailleurs réitéré dans le cadre des
discussions que nous avons pu avoir je
crois avec vous-même d'ailleurs lors de
nombreux plfss
et c'est vrai que la vision réduite que
nous avions des informations lors du
plfss uniquement sur les régimes de base
nous donner cette vision incomplète qui
d'ailleurs a amené parfois des débats
sur la réalité sur le fond déséquilibre
des systèmes de retraite
et puis une deuxième raison qui
nécessite à mon idée de voter contre
votre motion de rejet
c'est le fait que nous souhaitons ici
traduire ce que je vous expliquais tout
à l'heure la responsabilité je crois que
c'est quelque chose que nous avons en
commun la responsabilité que vous
appelez je crois vous aussi de vos voeux
de construire un système de retraite
solide durable
car si nous voulons collectivement tout
savoir de nouveaux droits pour nos
concitoyens il faut pouvoir avoir un
système qui soit à léquilibre
durablement car il n'y aura pas de
nouveaux droits s'ils ne sont pas
financés voilà monsieur le député stif
et le very pourquoi pour ma part
j'appellerai à voter contre votre motion
roger merci la parole est à monsieur
régis juanico
pour une explication de vote merci
monsieur le président le ministre
olivier ferrand citait dans son propos
introductif michel rocard qui dans sa
préface du livre blanc en 1991 disait il
n'y a pas de tâche plus fondamentale que
de traiter de façon exemplaire la
question des retraites
il oubliait de dire que michel rocard
disait aussi sans consensus nécessaire
100 ans de réflexion suffisant les
retraites il ya de quoi faire chuter il
ya quoi faire tomber cet oubli
gouvernement là votre contre-réforme des
retraites conduite dans une
impréparation totale caractérisé par son
amateurisme est tout sauf exemplaire
alors qu'elle touche à la vie
quotidienne de tous les français qu'elle
bouleverse leur profondeur le système de
répartition est solidaire des retraites
mise en place en 1945
votre réforme c'est celle des pieds
nickelés des briconautes
c'est le mépris de la mobilisation
mobilisation sociale sans précédent
depuis le 5 décembre dernier c'est le
mépris du parlement avec le choix d'une
procédure accélérée avec un débat
expéditif un texte à trous avec pas
moins de 29 ordonnance dessaisissant les
parlementaires qui vous demandait de
signer un chèque en blanc en particulier
sur les éléments financiers qui seront
traités dans une conférence qui a lieu
hors de ses murs
c'est un texte black-black-black bâclé
ni fait ni à faire avec une étude
d'impact indigente tronquée provoquant
un avis du compte
d'état un des plus sévères qu'il ait
jamais eu à écrire un texte à multiples
inconnues en particulier sur l'évolution
de la valeur du point
basé sur un indicateur le revenu moyen
d'activités improvisée de toutes pièces
en commission spéciale votre réforme
c'est la réforme du doigt mouillé
les français tentent de comprendre tout
comme nous dans quelles conditions ils
pourront partir à la retraite et avec
quels montants de pension
nous avons posé des questions précises
concrètes en commission spéciale vous
avez été incapable de les rassurer au
contraire votre usine à gaz anxiogène
vos approximations vous les avez plongé
les français dans un brouillard épais
avec l'injustice majeure de l'âge
d'équilibré du malus
vous allez faire la double peine pour
tous les futurs retraités nous voterons
la motion de rejet préalable le no merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur thierry benoit pour l'europe et
d agir
merci monsieur le président alors
d'emblée moi j'annonce qu'au nom du
groupe
udi agir et indépendants nous allons
voter contre cette motion de rejet
préalable et je vais redire ici ce que
j'ai dit en commission à savoir que les
centristes quelles que soient les bancs
sur lesquels ils se trouvent les
centristes de bonne foi doivent pouvoir
dire qu'au moins deux puis trois
législatures
ils soutiennent l'instauration d'un
régime universel de retraite par points
pour deux raisons essentielles tout
d'abord parce que c'est une demande des
français
le précédente orateurs faisait référence
à michel rocard
souvenons nous de l'instauration de la
retraite à 60 ans en 1981
ça a tenu une législature et d avril
1991 dans le livre blanc sur les
retraites préfacé par michel rocard
michel rocard annoncé lui même il ya
trente ans qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures nécessaires pour préserver notre
système de répartition par des retraites
dans ce projet tel qu'il est présenté
moi j'y vois deux spécificités qui sont
indispensables
le premier point c'est la mise en
extinction des régimes spéciaux de
retraite et le deuxième point c'est la
convergence
public privé dire aussi que s'il ya un
sujet sur lesquels les français
attendent
et depuis longtemps c'est bien sûr celui
des retraites dire que nous avons eues
en commission soixante quinze heures de
débats sur le projet de loi ordinaire et
plus de six heures sur le projet de loi
organique
moi je souhaite que nous puissions dès
aujourd'hui entrer au coeur de ce débat
et je souhaite aborder et faire des
contributions des propositions sur les
questions de la pénibilité des carrières
longues la question des petites
retraites notamment les petites
retraites agricoles des indépendants
commerçants artisans le sujet du cumul
emploi retraite et notamment les droits
nouveaux ouverts pour celles et ceux des
futurs retraités qui souhaiteront
poursuivre le cumul emploi-retraite donc
nous voterons contre cette motion de
rejet préalable
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le président vigier merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues une
immense majorité du groupe votera en
faveur de cette motion de rejet
préalable pour deux raisons majeures
la première j'ai écouté mon ami thierry
benoit avec lequel genre partage
beaucoup de valeurs centristes mais vous
savez était centriste c'est les mêmes
qui ont avec charles de courson et
d'autres porter l'idée d'une règle d'or
est porté l'idée que lorsqu'il ya un
mécanisme financier doit être sécurisé
et lorsqu'avec jeanine dubié nous avons
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
en commission spéciale malheureusement
nous amendements ont été déclarées
recevables et franchement comment parler
d'un équilibre financier si on en n'est
pas absolument certain et sur la valeur
du point
vous le savez mes chers collègues comme
nous lorsqu'on demande à l'insee dès
fabriquer un nouvel indice
je ne fais que dire que ce que vous
savez tous ça n'est pas de bonne manière
moi qui ai toujours été favorable à
cette réforme a point moi qui ai
toujours été favorable à l'extinction
des régimes spéciaux
oui mais mon cher collègue le rôle d'un
parlementaire
c'est aussi d'avoir tous les moyens
d'appréciation un moment ou un autre
donc je ne suis que le reflet de la voix
de mes collègues majoritaire qui
voteront contre tu vaux 3 en faveur
pardon ce projet de rejet préalable
voilà
merci monsieur le président vigier
rapport à l'état monsieur eric coquerel
chers collègues nous voterons pour cette
motion de rejet au projet de loi est
illégitime
il est illégitime car il n'a aucun
mandat électoral qui le suppose le
président bakr on avait dit qu'il ne
toucherait pas à l'âge de départ à la
retraite ni aux pensions vous fait les
deux il est illégitime parce que vous
avez la majorité des syndicats contre
vous il est illégitime parce que vous
avez la quasi totalité de ceux qui
produisent des richesses dans ce pays
qui s'y opposent donc la grande majorité
du peuple
il est illégitime et vous êtes du coup
obligé d'utiliser des méthodes non
démocratiques passage en force
ordonnance étude d'impact rues quais
jusqu'à la répression et l'intimidation
permanente du mouvement social il
étendit moquerait antidémocratique et
même contraire à l'esprit la
constitution celle du cnr monsieur
guérini que cyniquement vous citez je
cite qui garantit aux vieux travailleurs
la protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs
votre école civilisationnel fait l
inverse au point que votre rapporteur
monsieur pourquoi explique qu'elle a
pour but de bien vieillir au travail eh
bien nous ne voulons pas bien vieillir
au travail et votre culte sans cesse de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
ça signifie une chose vous proposer aux
gens d'être soi des travailleurs pauvres
soit de retraités pauvres soit ceux qui
les ont les moyens de recourir à la
retraite à capitalisation qui est le
véritable objectif de votre réforme
votre réforme est les productivistes
parce que vous n'imaginez comme solution
que le fait que chacun produisent
toujours plus pour s'en sortir
au moment où au contraire il faudrait
réfléchir à nos modes de production
votre réforme elle est illégitime
elle est anti démocratique elle est
contraire à la constitution
elle signifie à recul civilisationnel
elle et productiviste et pour cette
raison nous voterons sans hésiter
contrairement et je le regrette à ce
qu'ont fait nos doutes nos collègues
républicains tout à l'heure nous
voterons avec cohérence
la motion de rejet des républicains et
si elle n'est pas appliquée
c'est sûr qu'on veut mener une vie
d'enfer dans cette assemblée
jusqu'au retrait merci la parole est à
monsieur hubert wulfranc bien monsieur
le président chers collègues le groupe
gdr votre à cette motion des
républicains au titre de l' incurie au
titre de la curie de la majorité à
entrer dans un débat réellement
démocratique conséquent sur ce projet de
loi
major incurie vis-à-vis des français
incurie vis-à-vis des organisations
syndicales incurie vis-à-vis des élus et
des parlementaires un curry qui
dévoilait chaque jour et dévoile chaque
jour davantage
tout à la fois et l'attitude des
français et les éclairs cruellement sur
l'avenir compromis de ceux de la
sécurité du dernier âge de la vie cette
réforme
votre réforme c'est une taxe sur la vie
d'après une taxe sur la vie d'après qui
va épuiser les corps et les porte
monnaie des salariés c'est aussi et
concomitamment parce que votre réforme
est dans la droite ligne de la droite
anti sociales que vous êtes très
éloignée de la tradition communiste et
gaullistes issus de la cnr du cnr et
bien que nous voterons sans hésiter
cette motion de rejet
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur sacha oublié
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues les
républicains vous avez été un temps un
parti de gouvernement
en ce temps le 9 novembre 2010 vous avez
fait adopter un texte comportait un
article 16
un texte qui était invité par la cfdt et
qui prévoyait que une étude devait être
fait une réflexion nationale pour mettre
en oeuvre les conditions d'un régime
universel par points dans le respect du
régime par répartition c'est ce que nous
faisons ici et en proposant la motion
que vous proposez ici la motion de rejet
préalable
vous n'êtes ni responsable ni cohérent
pas responsable d'abord parce que si
cette notion venait à être adopté ce que
nous ne souhaitons pas alors l'équilibré
financier du système ne serait pas
garantie
si cette motion venait à être adoptée
alors la valeur du point
la garantie que le point de baissera pas
alors ce ne serait pas garantie nous ne
souhaitons pas et peut-être que vous
voulez pas que ce texte soit adopté pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'il aligne
le régime des parlementaires sur le
régime général
comme le veulent les sénateurs les
républicains et puis il y avait
également la forme
vous avez un projet c'est un mauvais
projet
le procès que vous proposez c'est celui
de porter l'âge légal de départ à 65 ans
et cela vous distingue de la
pantalonnade qui nous est menée ici pour
lequel aucune solution n'est apportée
aux français mais défendent et le
défendez cette solution qui n'est pas
acceptée par nos concitoyens parce que
nous des solutions
nous en avons à proposer et qu'il
s'agisse de la garantie des pensions de
réversion
qu'il s'agisse du minimum contributif
qu'il s'agisse du système universel pour
tous qu'il s'agisse de la fin des
régimes spéciaux
nous avons des solutions à proposer
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voterons contre cette motion de rejet
merci chers collègues
la parole est à mme constance le grip
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président pour
répondre à ce qui vient de nous être dit
concernant l'article 16 de la loi 2010
d'abord cet article 16 ans la loi de
2010 ça n'était pas la cfdt qui nous
l'avait souffle et nous avions
clairement pris position en faveur d'une
fusion entre le système public et le
système privé est ce que vous faites va
bien au delà est une version tout à fait
universaliste et égalitariste de la
réforme des retraites
nous voterons bien évidemment en faveur
de cette motion de rejet préalable
défendu par notre collègue stéphane very
je voulais revenir de quelques mots sur
l'avis du conseil d'état qui quand même
dans un avis d'une sévérité remarquer a
souligné les perspectives financières
lacunaire a fait savoir qu'il ne pouvait
pas garantir la sécurité juridique de ce
texte a également déploré le recours
trop abondants aux ordonnances qui nuit
à l'ensemble et la visibilité dans
l'ensemble nous voulons également
revenir sur le calendrier parlementaire
dans lequel vous souhaitez enfermé
l'assemblée nationale ce calendrier
parlementaire n'est pas raisonnable il
n'est ni réaliste ni tenable
il n'est pas respectueux des droits du
parlement il n'est pas respectueux des
droit d opposition
je rappelle qu'il ya eu quand même une
commission spéciale qui s'était auto
saborder qu'on n'a pas pu aller en
commission spéciale jusqu'au bout de
l'examen des deux projets de loi qu'il y
a eu également des délais de travail
infligé aux députés pour l'examen d'une
étude d'impact de plus de 1000 pages
tout à fait y est inconvenant et de
manière générale nous dénonçons
également dans ses études d'impact comme
l'a fait le président damien abad
d
un sincérité et des manques et des
failles tout à fait préjudiciable à un
travail éclairé raisonnable sera de la
représentation nationale et donc pour
toutes ces raisons
comme l'a dit notre orateur les
républicains nous souhaitons pour
échapper à l'improvisation et
l'impréparation dans laquelle nous
plonge le gouvernement qu'il puisse y
avoir du temps et un vrai travail en
profondeur collègues la parole comme
monsieur brayer ma bouche pour le modem
oui monsieur le président je 4motion 41
mille amendements je voudrais juste
signaler à nos collègues qui vont
vouloir voter cette motion de rejet que
nous ne sommes pas dans un
court-circuitage du débat parlementaire
au contraire je me demande même si c'est
pas une peur que vous avez cette peur de
débats du fond des choses est de
reconnaître que finalement ce système
universel de la réforme des retraites
est un système à la fois responsable et
juste
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
entre on entre on finalement dans l'état
providence du 20e siècle
c'est cela que nous voulons refonder en
profondeur c'est cela que nous voulons
bâtir dans un souci à la fois d'une
démarche progressive universel et dans
un souci constant de justice sociale
c'est un texte de responsabilité parce
qu'en inscrivant dans le cadre de la loi
organique est donc fondamental de notre
loi le principe d'équilibré financier
nous voulons rétablir la confiance de
nos concitoyens dans notre système de
répartition nous voulons en assurer la
soutenabilité pour nos enfants pour nos
petits enfants
nous voulons comme en 1945 nous
débarrasser des incertitudes du
lendemain pour nos concitoyens nous
voulons et même mieux réparer les
inégalités de ce2 douce du quotidien de
nos concitoyens qui sont dans le besoin
et ça nous sommes fidèles dans l'esprit
car la lie nous ne sommes pas des
littéraliste nous sommes dans l'esprit
de la réforme des ordonnances de 45 et
nous voulons pousser plus loin plus loin
pour que fronde et bâtir bâtir cet état
providence du xxème siècle que nous
voulons et que nous appelons
mais mes chers collègues ce projet de
loi organique est aussi un texte de
justice coeur battant de la république
sociale et je m'adresse au côté gauche
de l'hémicycle
c'est un projet de loi qui veut à la
fois traitées en dignité et en équité en
égalité l'ensemble de nos ensembles de
nos concitoyens si si mes chers
collègues et enfin la valeur du point en
temps parler elle sera inscrite dans le
marbre que salt valeur du point cela a
été dit mais c'est important de le
rappeler qu'ils ne qu'il ne baissera pas
mes chers collègues pour terminer
simplement rapidement il faut conclure
je oui nous voulons garantir les
solidarités intergénérationnelles merci
chers collègues je vais donc nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre aux voix
la motion de rejet préalable je vous
prie de bien vouloir regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos votants 240 exprimé
des 139 majorité 120 pour 94 contre 145
la motion de rejet préalable n'ait pas
adopté
je donne la parole aux présidents
chassaigne monsieur le président chers
collègues
l'acte que je vais produire est un acte
rare un acte fort puisque le précédent
remonte à 2008
il s'agit de s'appuyer sur l'article 11
de la constitution l'article 122 du
règlement intérieur pour déposer une
motion tendant à proposer au président
de la république de soumettre au
référendum le projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite
monsieur monsieur le président chers
collègues je prononce ces mots avec une
forme de d'émotion avec de la solennité
et je peux dire que nous avons réuni 60
signataires qui sont ici présents parce
qu'il faut au minimum 58 signataires qui
sont présents dans l'hémicycle et qui
puisse répondre à l'appel qui sera fait
par le président notre assemblée 60
signataires de différentes sensibilités
politiques je tiens à le dire dans leur
diversité qui pensent que le peuple doit
avoir la parole sur ce projet de loi
merci monsieur le président chassaigne
donc je vais s'il vous plaît je suspends
la séance de minutes personne ne bouge
nous vérifions les noms et ensuite je
ferai la peine deux minutes je dis ça
dans l'intérêt des pétitionnaires
très bien
en application de l'article 122 du
règlement j'ai reçu de monsieur fabien
roussel et de 60 de ses collègues une
motion tendant a proposé de soumettre au
référendum le projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite je vais
procéder à l'appel nominal des
signataires dans l'ordre figurant sur la
liste présentée à l'appui de la mention
madame valérie rabault monsieur
guillaume garot monsieur olivier faur
madame sylvie tall man
monsieur régis juanico monsieur luc
carvounas monsieur alain david jeu
christophe bouillon monsieur dominique
potier madame danielle obono madame
mathilde panneaux adam clémentine autain
madame bénédicte taurine monsieur michel
larive monsieur bastien la chaux madame
caroline fiat
monsieur jean luc mélenchon monsieur
alexis corbière monsieur ugo bernalicis
madame muriel resseguier monsieur fabien
roussel monsieur jean paul dufrègne
monsieur pierre dharréville monsieur
hubert wulfranc monsieur morita
hybrideurs phone monsieur sébastien
jumel
madame manuel la clé barre mon désir
excusez moi madame huguette bello
monsieur andré chassaigne monsieur
stéphane peu monsieur jean paul lecoq
monsieur gabriel serville madame marie
george buffet la mention monsieur alain
c'est pas bien brunel voilà ça
merci madame dubié jeunes in monsieur
david habib allah mme gisèle biémouret
alamichel victory madame george
pau-langevin madame laurence dumont
monsieur jean louis bricout monsieur
hervé saulignac madame josette manin
monsieur jérôme lambert
monsieur christian hutin madame sylvia
pinel monsieur françois michel lambert
monsieur paul andré comeau ban monsieur
paul molac monsieur michel castellane
jean-félix à quoi vivent
monsieur aviez breton madame christine
pires bonne madame cécile untermaier
monsieur adrien cat-nat ce monsieur loïc
prud'hommes
monsieur eric coquerel madame sabine
rufin rubin pardon et monsieur françois
ruffin et enfin madame karamanli
[Musique]
acte est donnée de la présence effective
en séance des signataires de la motion
la parole est à monsieur fabien roussel
pour présenter la motion pour une durée
ne pouvant excéder 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
je suis saisi sur le vote de la motion
référendaire par le groupe socialiste et
apparentés d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues déposé une
motion référendaire est un acte rare est
important comme l'a rappelé
solennellement le président chassaigne
et nous la soul mettons à votre vote
aujourd'hui avec 61 de mes collègues 61
députés attachés à la démocratie qui
dans leur diversité considère que ce
projet de loi
procédant à une réforme du système de
retraite inédite depuis 1945 ne peut
s'imposer dans une telle confusion et
dans un tel calendrier cet acte pose la
question de la souveraineté du peuple et
du rôle du parlement
depuis l'avènement du quinquennat et de
l'élection des députés dans la foulée du
sel du président de la république avec
l'inversion du calendrier
quels moyens on nos concitoyens pendant
cinq ans pour exprimer leurs opinions
pour exercer leur souveraineté pour
refuser une réforme qu'ils estiment
injuste c'est une vraie question qui
nous est posée aujourd'hui la
constitution française est là pour nous
rappeler les principes fondamentaux de
la souveraineté nationale et cela dès
son premier article
notre constitution infirme affirme je
cite la souveraineté nationale
appartient au peuple qui l'exercé par
ses représentants et par la voie du
référendum
elle pose le principe de la république
comme étant le gouvernement du peuple
par le peuple pour le peuple
elle rappelle enfin que cette
souveraineté est une et indivisible
puisque aucune section du peuple ni
aucun individu ne peut s'en attribuer
l'exercice
alors comment sortir de cette crise dans
laquelle notre pays est enfoncée depuis
maintenant plus de 70 jours suite à la
présentation de votre projet de loi
admettons ensemble qu'une telle
mobilisation et
edit dans la vème république jamais on
n'avait vu autant de professions
différentes descendre dans la rue
ouvrier du public comme du privé avocat
cadres enseignants personnels soignants
étudiants pompiers du monde de la
culture et de la création des
professions libérales et tant d'autres
encore crient leur inquiétude et leur
incompréhension
toutes les organisations syndicales se
montre toujours déterminé à obtenir de
véritables négociations pour améliorer
notre système de retraites mais pas pour
le casser comme prévu dans ce texte ni
avec une réforme paramétrique qui
demanderait aux français de travailler
plus longtemps
le gouvernement nous rappelle tous les
jours que le dialogue est ouvert depuis
plus d'un an
mais alors pourquoi nos concitoyens sont
toujours aussi nombreux à demander le
retrait de cette réforme les doutes et
les interrogations des syndicats
s'ajoutent à ceux du conseil d'état des
formations politiques très différentes
de gauche et de droite
des parlementaires y compris de la
majorité soulève tant de questions et
toujours sans réponse quel est son
financement
pourquoi tant de trous dans cette
réforme tant de zones blanches comme
celle sur la calcul du point monsieur le
ministre ou sur la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
pourquoi un tel recours massif aux
ordonnances à ces zones d'ombré s'ajoute
un calendrier à marche forcée
incompatible avec un examen serein et
approfondi de la réforme
vous avez choisi une procédure accélérée
pour étudier un texte dont les premiers
effets se feront sentir en 2022
on n'est pas là deux mois près tout de
même une réforme de notre système de
retraite
concernant tous les français et toutes
les générations mérite que nous
accordions tout le temps qu'il faut avec
l'objectif de rassembler la nation comme
le fit ambroise croizat en 46 il n'y a
pas urgence
le temps de la démocratie pour ce sujet
majeur ne peut pas être celui d'une
réforme imposée
en procédure accélérée en refusant
d'écouter le mouvement social ont refusé
en refusant de donner le temps du débat
au parlement
vous prenez un grand risque celui d'une
fracture profonde avec nos concitoyens
avec les syndicats avec les partenaires
sociaux
celui d'un fossé qui va continuer de se
creuser entre les députés et les
français est abîmée encore un peu plus
la démocratie
le moment est venu de mettre fin à
l'incompréhension et la colère de nos
concitoyens et de la meilleure façon qui
soit en démocratie en redonnant la
parole au peuple
seul le référendum permettra d'en sortir
par le haut peut-on imaginer qu'une
telle réforme aussi importante se fasse
sans le peuple où malgré le peuple voire
plus grave encore contre le peuple
n'avons nous pas le droit de jouer
nous n'avons pas le droit nous n'avons
pas le droit de jouer avec sa colère ni
d'alourdir son découragement
mes chers collègues le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
certes les moyens de sortir de cette
crise notamment en retirant ce texte
mais ils ne sont pas les seuls non ils
ne sont pas les seuls à pouvoir aider
notre vie démocratique à surmonter
l'épreuve qu'elle rencontre aujourd'hui
nous autres parlementaires tous ensemble
disposons également d'un levier très
efficace pour donner au peuple la
possibilité de surmonter sa défiance à
l'égard de ses représentants ce levier
c'est la motion référendaire prévu à
l'article 122 du règlement de notre
assemblée
cette procédure nous permet de proposer
au président de la république de
soumettre au référendum
cette réforme des retraites chacun
d'entre nous ici dispose de la faculté
d'en faire usage
chacun d'entre nous ici avec cette
motion à l'immense pouvoir que soit
sollicité l'avis de ses concitoyens
chacun d'entre nous ici en son âme et
conscience à cette responsabilité la
responsabilité de revenir aux fondements
de notre démocratie
entendre le peuple lui même loin de
s'opposer au suffrage universel
la motion référendaire renforce la
démocratie car elle offre une sortie de
crise digne et solennelle elle permettra
par exemple d'ouvrir de vraies
négociations pour améliorer le système
actuel nous vous en plomb nous vous
appelons d'ailleurs à voter cette motion
au nom de la fidélité supérieur que nous
devons aux peuples et qui en chacun
d'entre nous doit l'emporter sur tous
nos autres attachement aussi légitime
soit-il
nous ne vous demandons pas de contredire
en quoi que ce soit la légitimité du
président de la république ou du
gouvernement ni leur droit à mener la
politique sur laquelle ils se sont
engagés
la motion référendaire constituent au
contraire le recours en cas de
difficulté grave qui permet de vérifier
si la route est bonne ou s'il est
nécessaire d'en changer
oui le référendum est une solution de
sagesse
elle est réservée aux crises graves
comme celle que nous vivons depuis de
longs mois et dont l'issue ne peut plus
être raisonnablement trouvait en dehors
de nos concitoyens nous sommes nous
communistes de ceux qui disons que l'on
ne gouverne pas un pays par référendum
mais non ne gouverne pas non plus sans
écouter le pays la majorité vous vous
prétendez que bon nombre de nos
concitoyens vous demande de tenir bon
mais entendez-vous toutes celles et ceux
qui disent qu'ils ne veulent pas de
cette réforme
êtes vous seulement à l'écouté du
président de la république
où êtes-vous à l écoute de tous les
français l'histoire nous rappelle avec
force que la grandeur de la nation
française et d'accepter de retourner
vers le peuple
lorsque des circonstances majeur
l'imposent et de faire confiance à son
intelligence à sa capacité à comprendre
une loi
une réforme à juger si celle ci est
bonne ou mauvaise en 2005 sur le traité
constitutionnel européen que certains
annoncent est trop complexe
le référendum a donné lieu à un très
beau débat dans notre pays nos
concitoyens se sont emparés de ce traité
ligne par ligne avec passion et à
l'arrivée ils ont choisi la démocratie
quand elle fait le pari de
l'intelligence l'emportent toujours
certes trois ans plus tard avec une
violence inouïe est toujours vivace
certains ont préféré s'asseoir sur la
vie du peuple
mais ça c'est un autre débat aujourd'hui
chacune et chacun d'entre nous dans tout
le pays doit pouvoir se saisir du projet
de réforme des retraites
faisons confiance à l'intelligence du
peuple français n'insultons pas son
intelligence de grâce
les français doivent savoir ils doivent
découvrir par eux mêmes dans chaque
usine dans chaque atelier dans chaque
bureau dans chaque hôpital dans chaque
école
ce qu'il y a dans votre texte dans votre
texte que les députés communistes et gdr
et d'autres sur ses bancs comme mes
camarades insoumis demande le retrait à
rebours du progrès de civilisation de la
chance que représente l'allongement de
la durée de la vie il faut que les
français découvrent par eux mêmes
qu'avec ce texte ils devront travailler
plus longtemps jusqu'à 65 ans puis 66
ans et demi pour la génération 90
de fait en partant à 62 ans les futurs
retraités subir et des décotes
importantes sur leur pension de l'ordre
de 15%
c'est de cela dont il faut discuter avec
les français on pourrait y ajouter les
professions libérales comme les avocats
ou les kinés qui vont perdre la gestion
de leur caisse autonome et subir une
forte hausse de leurs cotisations
il faut débattre oui avec les français
de la part que notre pays veut consacrée
aux retraites
c'est là le fond
elle était de 6% du pib en 1950 et à la
toujours progresser pour tenir compte de
l'allongement de la durée de la vie elle
est aujourd'hui à 14% et nous produisons
quatre fois plus de richesses nous
considérons que cette part doit
continuer de progresser alors que ce
texte de loi envisage de la diminuer à
12,8 pour cent ce qui serait en totale
contradiction avec l'évolution naturelle
de la démographie qui voient augmenter
et c'est tant mieux
le nombre de personnes âgées de plus de
65 ans voilà pourquoi le montant des
pensions
leur évolution où l'âge de départ en
retraite seront dans votre projet les
seule variable d'ajustement de l'
équilibre financier recherché que dire
de la pénibilité en voulant faire des
économies sur notre système de retraite
en refusant de taxer le capital en
écoutant que le medef vous refuser de
prendre en compte la pénibilité
de nombreux travailleurs qu'ils soient
couvreur égoutiers bûcheron caissière
agriculteurs infirmières conducteur de
métro de train ou de bus sont écartés de
votre projet de loi et les femmes et les
femmes elles seront encore les victimes
de cette réforme laissé au bord du
chemin en art en oubliant celles qui
subissent entre autres le temps partiel
et qui aujourd'hui vivent avec 800 900
euros de salaire net
votre réforme c'est un véritable projet
de société tellement différent de ce qui
fait la force et l'originalité de la
nation française de tout cela mes chers
collègues il faut pouvoir en discuter
sincèrement les yeux dans les yeux avec
nos concitoyens qui pour 67 % sont
favorables à l'organisation d'un
référendum mais aussi permettre y
compris à vous qui défendez cette
réforme de pouvoir en démontrer les
bienfaits et les avantages engageons ce
débat à travers tout le pays
relevons le défi tous ensemble oui mes
chers collègues de la majorité
n'ayez pas peur de débattre devant nos
concitoyens cartes sur table projet
contre projet pour que chacun puisse
avancer
ses arguments selon sa sensibilité ses
convictions c'est le général de gaulle
qui a utilisé cinq fois le référendum en
dix ans et qui disait je cite la
démocratie se confond exactement pour
moi avec la souveraineté nationale la
démocratie c'est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple et la souveraineté
nationale c'est le peuple
exerçant sa souveraineté sans entrave la
démocratie mes chers collègues ne
s'exerce pas tous les 50 comme vous le
dîtes surtout quand le candidat devenu
président avait dit lors de sa campagne
qu'il n'augmenterait pas l'âge de départ
en retraite qu'il ne changerait pas les
règles de notre système par répartition
c'est pourquoi avec 61 députés venus de
tous horizons de groupes politiques très
différents et dans le respect de nos
opinions
nous nous adressons à vous tous chers
collègues en vous invitant à voter cette
motion référendaire
par ce vote
par ce vote nous pouvons tous en sambre
conquérir une part de la confiance
citoyenne dont notre démocratie manque
cruellement
la force de la nation française qui
s'est forgé en abolissant la monarchie
il y a deux cent trente ans réside dans
son peuple dont nous sommes ici les
humbles représentants et depuis le
peuple de france dans sa grande
diversité est très exigeant en matière
de démocratie et de souveraineté et il
n'aime pas être trompé alors donnons-lui
aujourd'hui le moyen d'être entendu
retrouvons en france le goût de la
politique du vote du débat digne sur le
fond et pas sur les personnes
redonnons le goût de la démocratie aux
françaises et aux français qui nous
suivent aujourd'hui nous observe et qui
veulent tout et tous restent maîtres de
leur choix et de leur destin merci
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
je constate qu'une partie d'entre vous
souhaitent soumettre en application de
l'article 122 du règlement de votre
assemblée de motion référendaire
comme j'ai pu le dire précédemment le
gouvernement compte bien non seulement
que l'assemblée nationale examine
l'intégralité des deux textes qui lui
sont soumis mais bien évidemment qu'ils
soient très largement adopté vous
opposer à ce projet de loi qui vise à
instaurer un système universel de
retraite est monsieur faure les c'est
tout à fait votre droit
ce que je comprends moyens c'est le
recours à cette motion référendaire
procédure exceptionnelle qui vise à
dessaisir le parlement de ses
prérogatives
alors je veux vous citez benjamin
constant
la démocratie représentative
c'est une procuration donnée à un
certain nombre d'hommes par le peuple
qui veut que ses intérêts soient
défendus
je ne veux pas vous prêtez monsieur le
président si chassaigne de mauvaise
intention mais votre motion sous-entend
que vous élus du suffrage universel ne
seriez pas légitime pour décider de
l'avenir de notre système de retraite
ensuite je veux faire une remarque
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans le
processus parlementaire avec à
référendum
il n'y a aucune possibilité d'améliorer
le texte
or c'est précisément ce que nous voulons
faire ici avec les représentants de
l'assemblée nationale c'est la méthode
du gouvernement et c'est mon engagement
c'est bien pour cela que j'ai passé plus
de 75 heures à la commission spéciale et
c'est bien pour cela que je resterais
ici
parmi les députés aussi longtemps que
nécessaire pour à la fois j'espère vous
convaincre de la justice que porte ce
texte mais aussi parce que je l'entends
l'améliorer au travers de vos
amendements et de ce que vous
souhaiteriez portée alors imaginons sur
le président chassaigne monsieur le
député roussel imaginons que cette
motion soit adoptée
je ne peux m'empêcher je ne peux
m'empêcher de me demander quelle est la
question qui serait posée aux françaises
et aux français pour ou contre un
minimum de pension à 85% pour contre un
système solidaire par répartition pour
ou contre le maintien des départs
anticipés pour celles et ceux qui
mettent leur vie en danger pour protéger
la nôtre pour ou contre le maintien de
42 régime pour rencontre le maintien
d'un système où les pensions des femmes
sont 40 % moins élevé que celles des
zones en réalité en réalité personne
n'est dupe ce que vous faites
mesdames et messieurs les députés
signataires de cette motion ne vous en
déplaise c'est utiliser un artifice de
procédure pour essayer d'empêcher la
très grande majorité de l'assemblée
nationale qui souhaite faire ce pourquoi
elle a été élue ce pourquoi des citoyens
comme moi ont fait le choix de
l'engagement examiner un projet de loi
en débattre le modifier l'améliorer en
refusant ce processus
je crois que vous refusez le débat
pourquoi
que craignez vous mesdames et messieurs
les députés dépassons ces manoeuvres
dilatoires
évitons les fausses querelles tenons
nous éloigner des facilités des
caricatures ou des postures la
démocratie représentative est la règle
la démocratie référendaire est
l'exception
le débat parlementaire constitue la
garantie d'un examen exhaustif par la
sérénité qu'ils apportent autant que par
les expertises qu'il comporte
c'est en tant que citoyen et anciens
parlementaires que je vous le dis faites
confiance à la démocratie représentative
soyons ensemble à la hauteur des enjeux
c'est par le débat ce débat que vous
essayer d'empêcher que nous pourront
éclairer les françaises et les français
sur nos objectifs et aussi je l'entends
nos différences mesdames et messieurs
les députés c'est pour cela que je vous
invite à rejeter massivement cette
motion référendaire
je vous remercie merci ministre monsieur
fort pour une explication de vote
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je viens de vous écouter et
vous de nous dire que vous étiez donc
fidèle aux engagements que j'ai pris
pendant l'élection présidentielle pas
vous le résident de la république
la première achète la première vérité
c'est qu'il en est rien le président
s'est engagé sur un système à points que
même ceux qui sont favorables au système
à points
aujourd'hui considèrent dans les tacles
de la réforme comme injuste et par
ailleurs vous le savez il s'était engagé
à ne pas toucher à l'âge de départ à la
retraite vous y revenez
et donc est donc la raison imposerait
que puisque les français n'ont jamais
été consulté à ce sujet qu'il le soit
désormais mais j'entends ce que vous
dites vous nous dites moi je souhaite en
fait que le débat puisse intervenir
les commissions aller jusqu'au bout ça
tombe bien nous aussi on veut le débat
jusqu'au bout vous dites que le
parlement est parfaitement légitime pour
aller jusqu'au bout de ce débat très
bien et bien alors je vous le dis moi je
suis prêt à ne pas voter cette motion
référendaire à une condition est une
condition exclusive que vous preniez
l'engagement maintenant que le 49-3 ne
sera jamais invoquée par le gouvernement
si tel était le cas alors nous pourrions
considérer que votre parole vaut quelque
chose si vous ne prenez pas l'engagement
c'est que vous avez vous même prévu
d'abréger les débats
et si vous avez prévu engagé le diriger
les débats alors il faut effectivement
que le peuple puisse trancher ce que
nous ne pouvons pas à trancher ici en
clarté et en responsabilité merci
la parole est à madame agnès firmin le
bodo pour le groupe d agir
merci monsieur le président notre groupe
ne soutiendra pas cette motion
référendaire
parce que nous ne partageons ni votre
analyse niveau conclusion vous vous êtes
prononcé lors des débats en commission
pour une retour un retour de l'âge de la
retraite à 60 ans vous le savez c'était
une erreur que nous payons encore
aujourd'hui ça n'est ni réaliste ni
finançable la réalité c'est que si nous
revenons à 60 ans noro traité vers une
baisse significative de leur pension ou
pire ne toucherait plus de pension du
tout alors que le déséquilibre entre
cotisants et pensionnés n'a jamais été
aussi élevé en réalité ce que vous
voulez ça n'est pas soumettre ces
projets de loi au référendum mais
retardé son examen en séance publique m
c'est dommage parce que l'examen en
séance permettra d'entendre les
arguments et les propositions de tous et
toutes et d'enrichir ce texte
c'est particulièrement dommage parce que
l'examen en séance publique permettrait
d'obtenir du gouvernement
nous le souhaitons tous des réponses
importantes par exemple sur la
révocation des retraites des
agriculteurs existence c'est-à-dire ceux
qui ne sont pas pris en compte dans le
projet de loi
notre groupe a d'ailleurs déposé des
amendes
en ce sens ne nous privons pas de ce
débat là qui est important et très
attendu ne nous privons pas également de
voter des mesures de justice en faveur
des femmes
ne nous privons pas non plus de trouver
dans ces discussions des moyens de mieux
prendre en compte l'usure au travail et
la pénibilité ou bien le cumul
emploi-retraite notre assemblée doit
prendre toute sa place dans le débat et
dans la fabrication la loi nous avons
été élus pour cela et ce mandat nous
oblige
plutôt que de priver la représentation
nationale d'un débat nécessaire et un gi
menthe et avançons et des pâtons projet
contre projet notre groupe votera contre
cette motion référendaire
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur présent vigier merci monsieur
le président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues c'est bien l'écouter ce
qu'a dit notre collègue jumelles tout à
l'heure et d'ailleurs à cet homme des
membres de mon groupe ont voté cette
motion référendaire l'ont signé avec eux
pour autant je voudrais dire que je ne
voterai pas en faveur de cette motion
référendaire
et je vais vous dire pourquoi mes chers
collègues nous avons tous été élus en
dix ans depuis de longues années que le
parlement chaque jour perdais un peu
plus de son influence on ne peut pas
dire d'un côté que l'affaiblissement du
parlement est permanent et monsieur le
ministre je vous le dis avec force
attention attention à ne pas brusquer
les choses pour aller sur un 49 3 qui
serait un aveu d'impuissance et qui
conduirait sur l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires l'action publique à une
impuissance chronique et le débat
parlementaire mes chers collègues qui
doit avoir lieu jusqu'au bout la seule
difficulté monsieur le ministre quand
j'apprends il ya quelques minutes que la
plupart de nos amendements et notre
groupe on a donné poser moins de 80 on
peut pas nous opposer le fait que l'on
ait pris une position politique ou
politicienne et quand la moitié de ces
amendements sont en train de tomber
alors que justement on parle du
financement attention à la dérive
je peux comprendre que certains soient
tentés par ces motion référendaire
mais demain mes chers collègues croyez
vous que nos concitoyens soit en
capacité de voter oui ou non sur une
réforme de retraites quelle réforme
c'est ça la vraie
difficulté alors je vous le dis avec
force je vous le dis avec force
attention au chemin que nous empruntons
et j'ai demandé monsieur le président et
vous le savez à ce que l'on prolonge les
débats même après les municipales
il s'agit des 40 prochaines années il ne
s'agit pas dans les bas de quelques
semaines prenons le temps de débattre
sinon ce sera le temps de l'impuissance
publique collective
merci françois ruffin
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr qu'on le veut ce référendum
bien sûr qu'on veut le voir le savoir si
les français à valve aux bobards parce
qu'on a entendu quoi comme refrain tout
l'après-midi justice sociale justice
sociale et cutter et distribution dans
votre bouche justice sociale j'ignore si
nous devons en rire ou en pleurer
vous qui avez rejeté le conte jeu de
deuil ici il ya quinze jours
vous qui jeudi dernier vous êtes
s'opposer seul seul contre la gauche
seul contre la droite
vous qui vous êtes opposé seul à des
mesures en faveur des personnes
handicapées
vous qui avez fabriqué 400000 pop de
plus en un an tandis que les plus riches
décolleté 4,5 milliards d'euros
la voilà votre justice sociale dans
votre bouche justice sociale mais c'est
le loup qui promet de devenir végétarien
d'ailleurs le loup est sorti du bois
vous l'avez vu cette publicité d'axa qui
présente votre réforme avec la création
d'une retraite à points je cite le
groupe financier la baisse programmée
des pensions retraites
pour combler cette baisse axa of bien
sûr de cotiser un plan épargne retraite
la voilà la vérité la voilà la vérité
proclamée par vos amis d'axa par vos
amis de blackrock
la voilà la vérité déjà annoncées par
françois fillon
le système parfois ça permet de baisser
chaque année le niveau des pensions
le voilà le hold-up préparé dans l'ombre
mené en procédure accélérée avec vos
amis vos amis financiers vos amis qui
vous finance un butin de 300 milliards
oui ça fait saliver
cette fois il faut donc que le loup se
déguise que vous répéter en boucle et
cuites et dialogues redistribution
justice sociale mais c'est comme chez
orwell dans la novlangue d'orwell tous
les maux soliste à l'envers justice
signifie bien sûr injustice non nous
n'avons pas confiance
aucune aucune aucune confiance en vous
les français n'ont aucune confiance en
vous et vous le savez vous le savez
c'est pourquoi vous allez refusé ce
référendum parce que vous voulez bel et
bien les entendre et financiers mais pas
les français
merci monsieur débuté la parole est à
madame huguette bello
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président la crise
actuelle est gravissime
elle s'exprime dans tout le pays et
montre l'inquiétude que provoque cette
réforme
le référendum permettra d'en sortir par
le haut c'est à dire par le peuple
car le haut démocratie c'est le peuple
67% des français se sont prononcés en
faveur d'un référendum le peuple n'a pas
effacé de sa mémoire
l'élan des grandes conquêtes sociales ap
d'après la libération il refuse que cet
élan toujours vivace soit définitivement
jeté au panier de l'impossible
imagine-t-on vraiment qu'il supporterait
sans broncher le sentiment d'une telle
défaite sans remous s'éclatant ou plus
redoutable encore sans une tenace
amertume secrète
pense-t-on qu'on en oublierait sans
doute son irritation son mécontentement
à l'eau même que la sévérité des plus
hautes autorités administratives leur a
fait solennellement tecau voici ce que
signifie notre système de retraite ce
qu'il dit de notre cohésion sociale de
notre façon française d'être ensemble
ignore-t-on de quelle symbolique
l'histoire la charge et la réforme comme
nous le rappelle fort justement le
conseil d'état a pour but de transformer
pour les dessins du à venir un système
social qui constitue l'une des
composantes majeures du contrat social
dans l'impasse où nous sommes enfoncés
la motion référendaire est désigne ainsi
la seule issue possible
allume la seule lumière capable
d'éclairer dans une affaire aussi grave
les rengaines de la commune
communication et de la prétendue
pédagogie sonne faux nous avons besoin
d'entendre le peuple lui même sa voix
venues de loin
sa musique véridique lorsque la musique
est belle
tous les hommes sont égaux n'ayons pas
peur du peuple votant cette motion merci
madame le député la parole et à monsieur
jean le cam
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues vous voulez nous faire croire
que la voie référendaire est nécessaire
car les français seraient contre c'est
toi après nous avoir dit la république
c'est moi
vous nous dites nous savons ce que veut
le peuple mais mes chers collègues vous
nous avait déjà fait le coup
il ya quelques mois avec aéroports de
paris ici vous nous avez dit que tous
les français étaient contre que le monde
entier était contré les français vous
ont répondu vous vous êtes trompé
seulement un million de français ont
signé autre référendum
aujourd'hui si chaque français peut
émettre des réserves ou des
interrogations sur tel ou tel point de
la loi sur les retraites
on peut les comprendre et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut un débat mais ils sont
largement favorables à chacun des
piliers de cette loi le système le
système par répartition
ils sont pour et nous le pérennisons la
fin des régimes spéciaux ils sont pour
et nous créons le système universel le
système un point les français y sont
familiarisés avec aj carco et il est
préconisé par la majorité des syndicats
majoritaires
le système financier les français sont
pour il est consubstantiel évidemment au
régime par répartition et enfin les
nouveaux droits sociaux
les français sont pour comment
pouvez-vous encore comment pouvez vous
vous regardez dans une case y est contre
les nouveaux droits sociaux
arrêté dans une démocratie
représentative
le débat parlementaire et la garantie
d'un examen exhaustif et d'une
discussion ouverte
l'adoption cette motion référendaire
aboutirait nous empêchait nous
parlementaires de nous exprimer de
débattre et d'ailleurs pourquoi un seul
référendum pourquoi pas quarante et un
mille référendum pour chacun d'eux un
mot non tout ciselés avec tellement de
netteté nous députés de la majorité
nous ne fuirons pas notre responsabilité
les français nous aurait vu sur un
programme sans lequel figure et c'est
très fort et dans deux ont été jugés sur
nos résultats
merci la parole la parole est à monsieur
gérard cherpion
[Applaudissements]
quand les coudes dans le calme merci
monsieur le président moi je peux
entendre les frustrations qui sont liés
à l'examen tronqué de ce projet de loi
et l'absence d'un débat de fond qui
d'ailleurs s'est traduit par l'arrêt de
l'examen du texte en commission spéciale
ça cela justifie effectivement qu'il y
ait des collègues qui souhaitent un
référendum
oui le référendum est une option qui a
été voulu par le général de gaulle
laquelle nous sommes attachés nous
républicain mais aujourd'hui nous
voulons un débat à l'assemblée nationale
nous ne sommes pas nous souhaitons en
véritablement une réforme du système de
retraite nous avons d'ailleurs présenté
un projet nous voulons le défendre
projet contre projet nous voulons un
système de base limitée à un plafond de
la sécurité sociale et ensuite trois
piliers public privé indépendant en
respectant la spécificité des métiers et
leurs difficultés
ce débat est nécessaire pour
sensibiliser les français sur les sur
les réalités de cette réforme qui est
aujourd'hui dans l'état du texte est
injuste non financées et dont
l'universalité s'étiole de jour en jour
avec les annonces qui sont faites par
différentes professions
nous voulons défendre notre projet je
souhaite qu'il puisse se dérouler nous
souhaitons qu'il puisse se dérouler
jusqu'à son terme
aussi dans ces conditions notre groupe
ne prendra pas part au vote
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame nathalie et limaces merci merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues le recours à cette motion
référendaire sonne comme un aveu d'échec
des députés qui la sollicitent
c'est l'ultime recours refusant le débat
et l'opposition constructive
vous vous drapez dans des procédures
parlementaires pour faire obstruction un
projet de société qui a déjà été soumis
à l'approbation de nos concitoyens eh
oui
l'instauration d'un système de retraite
par points la suppression des régimes
spéciaux et est écrit noir sur blanc
dans le projet du candidat macron élu
démocratiquement président de la
république alors je m'étonne je m'étonne
et je m'interroge pourquoi cette
procédure n'a t'elle pas été déclenchée
par le groupe communiste lors de la
réforme touraine alors même qu'elle ne
figurait pas dans le programme de
françois hollande un an auparavant
et quand bien même
et quand bien même un référendum aurait
lieu quel serait votre position celle
d'une eau celle de l'immobilisme celle
de la conservation d'un système injuste
et inégalitaire qui octroie des
avantages démesurés à certains et qui
oblige les autres à travailler toujours
davantage
est-ce que c'est cela votre vision de la
justice sociale eh bien ce n'est pas la
nôtre
ainsi vous souhaitez que les
agriculteurs ne bénéficie pas d'un
minimum de retraite à 1000 euros
ainsi vous ne souhaitez pas ouvrir des
droits à la retraite aux aidants aux
chômeurs aux étudiants en stage aux
femmes et aux plus fragiles d'entre nous
le temps du débat celui de la
représentation nationale elle à l'ordre
du jour nous offre plus de trois
semaines pour avoir un débat danse et
constructif
une réforme qui viendra structurer notre
société oui au pari de l'intelligence
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire rose c'est vous saisissez ce débat
le groupe modem évidemment ne soutiendra
pas c'est bien sûr si madame la députée
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre aux voix
la motion référendaire je vous prie de
bien vouloir gagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos votants 230 exprimé
230 majorité 116 pour 70 contre 160
la motion référendaire n'est pas adopté
la parole est à madame valérie rabault
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues votre réforme des
retraites comporte en réalité de réforme
la création d'un régime que vous
qualifiez d'universel et l'a13 la
transition entre le régime actuel et
votre régime universel
c'est donc un big bang et je pèse mes
mots un big bang que vous lancez et quel
que soit ce que l'on en pense
selon ray nécessité un minima sérieux
rigueur et non l'amateurisme que
désormais vous renvendiqué c'est parce
que c'est parce que le sérieux et la
précision
sens tu lances merci monsieur le
président c'est parce que c'est parce
que le sérieux et la ce et la précision
sont absents de votre étude d'impact
comment groupe a décidé de lancer une
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
cette même étude d'impact
cette commission pour an pendant 6 mois
auditionnés sous serment
tous les responsables politiques et
administratifs qui ont travaillé sur
cette réforme
elle pourra effectuer des saisies sur
pièces et sur place dans les bureaux des
administrations
j'espère qu'elle permettra d'apporter
les réponses que jusque là vous avez
refusé au delà de cette impréparation
coupable que nous dénonçons le texte de
la réforme que vous présentez diffère
profondément des objectifs de justice
que vous prenez le 11 décembre dernier
le premier ministre a annoncé une grande
réforme sociale
lorsque vous appelez une réforme sociale
va pénaliser l'ouvrier par rapport au
cadre
ainsi pour la première fois depuis 1945
le système de malus qui s'applique quand
on ne remplit pas toutes les conditions
pour avoir une retraite à taux plein va
reposer sur l'âge réel de départ à la
retraite et non sur la durée de
cotisation c'est un changement majeur
mes chers collègues de la majorité que
vous instaurez c'est un change
antisociales ainsi prenons le cas d'un
ouvrier qui commence à travailler à 20
ans qui a cotisé 43 ans il va partir à
la retraite à 63 ans avec votre système
il va subir une décote de 10% mes chers
collègues 10% et ce toutes les années de
sa retraite pas uniquement la première
année chaque année chaque année sa
retraite sera inférieur de 10% 1
contrario le cadre qui commence à
travailler à 24 ans parce qu'il a eu la
chance de pouvoir faire des études et
qui cotisent 43 ans partira à la
retraite à 67 ans et bien ce cadre là
vous proposer de lui donner un bonus
mes chers collègues avec vous là vous
aurez un régime anti sociale qui va
pénaliser l'ouvrier qui commence à
travailler à 20 ans et qui donnera un
bonus aux cadres qui partie commencera à
travailler à 24 ans vous vendez votre
réforme en tentant de nous faire croire
que là aussi les femmes seraient les
grandes gagnantes
alors je vais vous soumettre à nouveau
un exemple sous les yeux prenons
l'exemple d'une femme qui a commencé à
travailler à 22 ans comme salarié qui a
un enfant et qui part à la retraite à 63
ans avec le système actuel
elle bénéficiera quand elle partira
d'une d'une retraite à taux plein grâce
aux huit trimestres de majoration qui
sont aujourd'hui en vigueur
avec le système que vous voulez mettre
en place cette femme subira une décote
de 5% sur sa retraite à taux plein pour
un départ au même âge des femmes dans ce
cas là il y en a des millions dans notre
pays et vous refusé d'en parler ici dans
cet hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
enfin votre réforme nous ferait croire
qu'il n'y aurait que des gagnants
alors monsieur le ministre je vais vous
soumettre les casses ou suivant sous les
yeux et vous nous direz si oui ou non
ils sont gagnants avec votre réforme
prenons le cas de citoyens nés en 1990
ils vont donc être concernés par votre
réforme dans votre étude d'impact tous
les citoyens commencent à travailler à
22 ans et ils partent tous à la retraite
à 65 ans et le nouveau régime universel
tout le monde commenceraient à
travailler à 22 cents donc je vais
reprendre votre hypothèse monsieur
premier monsieur le ministre
un casse prenant à un citoyen qui
partent à la retraite à 65 ans qu'ils
soient de la génération 90 et qui ai
commencé à travailler à 22 ans avec
votre âge les led votre réforme l'âge
d'équilibré de 66 ans et trois mois
cela signifie que pour toute cette
génération il va y avoir un malus
prenons le cas d'un fonctionnaire
territorial catégorie b sans enfant
cette personne avec le système actuel
aurait une retraite de deux mille 142
euros par mois avec votre système
elle tombera à 2109 euros par mois ce
qui lui fait une baisse annuelle de
pouvoir d'achat 396 euros
prenons le cas d'un salarié du secteur
privé non cadres sans en changer conclut
monsieur président oui avec le système
actuel il aurait 2478 euros par mois
avec votre système ses 2300 39 euros par
mois une perte de pouvoir d'achat de
1600 euros sur l'année tous ces exemples
là monsieur le ministre vous ne voulez
pas l'avoir mais c'est la france c'est
la france et c'est celle dont nous vous
parlerons je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à mme agnès firmin le bodo pour dix
minutes pour le groupe u10 j'y réponde
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mais sherkole madame la
présidente de la commission spéciale mes
chers collègues notre système de
retraite constitue un pilier de notre
pacte social
le réformer de façon globale et
systémique c'est ouvrir une réflexion
sur le temps long s'est interrogé le
modèle de société auquel nous aspirons
et que nous souhaitons préserver ce
nouveau siècle c'est celui de défis
cruciaux à relever pour notre pays et la
société
je pense aux défis du changement
climatique mais aussi au défi du
vieillissement dans nos sociétés
industrialisées
il modifie nos rapports aux risques et à
la mort il crée des angoisses et des
inquiétudes nouvelle je pense également
aux mutations du travail le travail
c'est un des lieux essentiels ou la
personne établie son rapport au monde
c'est l'un des lieux privilégiés où la
personne se définit et souvent
s'émancipe
c'est aussi parfois un lieu de
souffrance et se doit d'être d'être
prises en compte les mutations du
travail au 21ème siècle dont nous sommes
moins d'avoir pris la mesure
ont rendu ces définitions mouvante et
instable les parcours professionnels se
diversifie les mobilités s'accroissent
les trajectoire linéaire au sein d'un
même entreprises sont moins fréquentes
loin d'être figée notre société et donc
vivante diverse plurielle c'est une
force pour l'avenir
cela peut également être mal vécue lors
des mutations s'accompagnant d'une
remise en cause d'une dégradation de ces
identités professionnelles les
oppositions et les inquiétudes
nombreuses exprimés ces derniers mois
face à cette réforme dépasse ainsi la
simple question des retraites
nous raisonnons encore trop souvent à
partir d' identité professionnelle
passée qui continue de fait à structurer
le débat public alors que dans le même
temps certaines catégories de la
population ont connu des changements de
situation important parfois dans le sang
en déclassement ou d'une précarisation
cela a pu créer des incompréhensions et
des sentiments d'injustice
je pense en particulier aux enseignants
dans le rôle de la socialité de notre
solide société est fondamentale la
réforme des retraites
l'immense mérite de mettre à jour
l'injustice que constitue leur situation
il faut le dire avec vigueur nous avons
depuis trop longtemps négligé la
situation de ceux qui instruisent nos
enfants les concours attire de moins en
moins là la fonction la plus son
prestige passé nous reculons chaque
année dans les classements
internationaux avec les enseignants nous
regrettons amèrement ce manque de
reconnaissance contradictoire avec
l'importance de leur mission
il est plus que temps de prendre ce
sujet à bras le corps et de réaffirmer
le contrat qui lie la société toute
entière à ceux qui font vivre notre
école c'est l'avenir de nos enfants
notre capacité à les rendre libres de
leur jugement à en faire des citoyens
pleinement actif qui est en jeu le
gouvernement a déjà apporté quelques
pistes pour améliorer les carrières des
enseignants c'est positif
il faudra néanmoins apporter une réponse
claire et sans ambiguïté à l'ensemble du
corps enseignant sur le calendrier de
revalorisation futur et leur montant
c'est un enjeu essentiel
notre groupe il sera attentif le système
de retraite d'un pays en dit long sur sa
façon de traiter l'égalité et l'équité
aujourd'hui fondées sur des solidarités
interprofessionnel de métier de corps il
ne répond plus aux besoins de protection
nouveau que ces mutations du travail en
jeu
par manque de lisibilité il crée de
l'anxiété la multiplication des réformes
paramétriques depuis 20 ans a d'ailleurs
une conséquence logique celle d'
entraîner une perte de confiance dans
l'ensemble du système
c'est particulièrement le cas chez les
jeunes générations par son opacité
il crée de la défiance est nourrie des
procès en injustice par sa complexité y
conduit au non recours au droit
notre système de retraite doit en
conséquence devenir plus juste plus
équitable plus solidaire ce qui serait
irresponsable aujourd'hui ce serait de
ne pas anticiper ces mutations profondes
c'est une exigence que nous portons pour
les gêner aux rapts génération actuelle
mais aussi pour nos enfants
la responsabilité c'est aussi de pouvoir
regarder les futures générations sans
rougir
parce que nous avons garanti les
équilibres financiers du système à ce
titre nous saluons la création d'une
règle d'or qui garantirait à la fois le
niveau des pensions et des équilibres du
système la responsabilité face aux
déficits c'est la condition de la
crédibilité de notre système
la responsabilité c'est d'avoir corrigé
les fragmentations et des ruptures de
droit face à la retraite si universelle
ne veut pas dire uniforme
il ne veut pas dire non plus régime
d'exception dès lors il était légitime
de supprimer les régimes spéciaux ce que
les français réclamaient depuis
longtemps
ce sera chose faite avec cette réforme
la création d'un système universel de
retraite par points constitue
indéniablement un défi ambitieux et un
bouleversement sans précédent depuis
notre groupe plaide depuis plus
longtemps en faveur d'un régime de
retraite par points nous sommes
convaincus qu'il s'agit d'un mode de
calcul plus juste plus lisible il est
mieux à même de concrétiser les
engagements respectifs de chacun envers
la société et le contrat qui les lie
cette réforme doit par ailleurs être
l'occasion de protéger davantage en
luttant contre les précarités en prenant
mieux en compte les carrières hachées
mais aussi les différentes formes de
pénibilité notamment par la création
d'une visite obligatoire en fin de
carrière pour les métiers à risques
c'est une demande ancienne de notre
groupe nous en félicitons elle doit
permettre de mieux protéger les femmes
face à la retraite alors que les
inégalités de pensions sont réels
aujourd'hui entre les femmes et les
hommes
aujourd'hui les pensions des femmes sont
encore inférieures
2 42% à celle des hommes ces inégalités
sont d'abord le reflet des inégalités
professionnelles
elle reflète également la différence
d'impact de l'éducation d'un enfant sur
les carrières des pères et des mères ce
projet de loi déploie tout un ensemble
de mesures qui permettront d'aplanir ces
différences et nous nous en réjouissons
elle doit féliciter les bolides mobilité
professionnelle et favoriser les prises
de risques dans la carrière en
garantissant qu'un changement d'emploi
ne soit pas synonyme de perte de droits
elle doit mieux protéger contre les
accidents de la vie nous allons la prise
en compte de la situation spécifique des
proches aidants pour les droits à la
retraite
il s'agit d'une reconnaissance
nécessaire pour prendre en compte le
dévouement quotidien dont ils font
preuve parfois au détriment de leur
santé ou de leur carrière
professionnelle au sujet des professions
libérales
notre groupe plaide pour l'inscription
dans la loi du principe du maintien des
réserves dans les caisses des régimes
autonome sur ce sujet il faut rassurer
les professions libérales et les
indépendants est précisé dans la loi les
résultats des concertations nous
porterons des amendements en ce sens il
faudra être particulièrement attentif au
respect des droits acquis durant la
transition entre anciens et nouveaux
systèmes nous proposons une évaluation à
mi-parcours des ordonnances dédié la
liberté la lucidité mais aussi la
responsabilité
ce sont des convictions qui structurent
et oriente engagement politique de notre
groupe
je les ai déjà souligné en commission
vous ne trouverez à vos côtés lorsqu'il
s'agira de prendre des mesures
courageuses et responsables garantissant
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite nous vous accompagnerons donc
lors de l'examen de ces projets de loi
tout en portant plusieurs amendements
visant à le compléter
ainsi nous proposons la création de
dispositifs de tutorat pour favoriser la
transmission des savoirs au sein des
entreprises entre les générations
le passage à la retraite devrait être
ressenti comme un couperet mais bien
comme un moment de transmission
bénéficie pour celui qui 120 comme le
nouvel arrivant nous proposons également
d'ouvrir un nouveau droit afin de
permettre aux personnes mariées ou lié
par un pacs de donner une partie de
leurs points à leurs conjoints afin
qu'ils puissent partir en retraite
ensemble ce projet de loi consacre la
préférence collective de notre pays pour
un système de retraite par répartition
nous considérons cependant qu'il doit
pas conduire à escamoter tout débat sur
l'intérêt d'une épargne
pour tous nous porterons également des
propositions afin d'ouvrir le débat sur
cette question alors que nous ont
examiné près de quarante mille
amendements
permettez moi enfin de regretter la
démarche de certains groupes politiques
et les manoeuvres d'obstruction qui ne
garantissent pas notre assemblée qui ne
grandissent pas notre assemblée
la liberté d'expression est une
condition de l'exercice de la démocratie
est dans un régime parlementaire cela
passe notamment par le droit d'amender
un texte
mais quand ce droit est utilisé non pas
pour porter la parole du peuple mais
pour l'enfermer dans une sclérose du
débat parlementaire
il est non seulement inutile mais aussi
dangereux pierre mendés france disait la
démocratie c'est beaucoup plus que la
pratique des élections et le
gouvernement de la majorité
c'est un type de moeurs de vertus de
scrupules de sens civique de respect de
l'adversaire
c'est un code moral alors chers
collègues faisons montre de sens civique
et de morale soyons exemplaires et digne
de notre démocratie représentatif
agissons ensemble de façon constructive
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le président
vigier pour 15 minutes
c'est le président seul ministre madame
la présidente de la commission mesdames
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues les jours heureux les gens
heureux c'est les titres lumineux d'un
texte court mais fondateur celui du
conseil national de la résistance signé
le 15 mars 1944
c'est le titre d'un programme écrit dans
la clandestinité et pourtant résolument
tourné vers l'avenir
c'est le souvenir d'une france meurtrie
enquête d'union et de reconstruction
qu'ils soient gaullistes centristes
socialistes communistes tous ont risqué
leur vie pour contribuer à l'écriture de
ce programme
c'est la promesse de bâtir un modèle de
protection sociale qui renforce la
solidarité et la dignité
les jours heureux c'est là mon projet de
réforme d'ampleur qui ont façonné notre
pays au lendemain de la guerre et qui le
structurent encore aujourd'hui c'est la
sécurité sociale les prestations
familiales l'indépendance de la presse
la renaissance des syndicats mais aussi
l'assurance vieillesse et bien sûr les
retraites pour tous
si la non du projet de loi dont nous
allons aujourd'hui débattent à susciter
autant des mobilisations parfois
violentes c'est aussi parce que les
français restent profondément attachés à
ces jours heureux
j'ai la conviction qu'il y en chacun
d'entre nous l'espoir de préserver un
modèle social mais aussi de l'améliorer
de le renforcer
et c'est ce que cet espoir qui rend nos
débats si passionné
monsieur le ministre vous le savez
réformer notre système de retraites
c'est proposer un véritable projet de
société
réformer le système des retraites s'est
engagé notre pays et les concitoyens
pour de nombreuses années
c'est promettre aux générations qui
cotisent aujourd'hui qu'elles
continueront de percevoir les fruits de
ce système de protection demain c'est
garantir la raison d'être de notre
modèle social
c'est resté fidèle à leur donnant du 4
octobre 1945
j'ouvre les guillemets débarrasser nos
concitoyens de l'incertitude du
lendemain fermez les guillemets et c'est
en ce sens que la clé de notre système
social cher collègue la clé pour mener à
bien toute réforme c'est la confiance la
confiance dans la solidité et la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
la confiance dans une gouvernance en
phase avec la société
la confiance aussi dans ceux qui
décident aujourd'hui de changer les
règles de notre système
au fond ces projets de société doit
emporter l'adhésion la plus large
possible celle des partenaires sociaux
celle du parlement mais aussi celle de
nos concitoyens avec cette réforme de
retraites ce que le gouvernement demande
à sa majorité à notre groupe
parlementaire liberté territoire mais
également l'opposition n'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une question de confiance
or monsieur le ministre force est de
constater que depuis le début de
l'examen du texte la confiance s'étiole
tandis que les questions s'amplifie je
peux l'affirmer avec d'autant plus de
force et vous l'avez compris que j'ai
défendu la mise en place d'un système de
retraite universel par points depuis de
longues années
cette réforme est indispensable pour
lutter contre les injustices qui
caractérise le système actuel et qui
frappe aujourd'hui les femmes les
métiers pénibles dangereux les carrières
longues ou haché ou encore
certaines professions indépendantes et
j'ai une pensée toute particulière pour
les agriculteurs les constats que vous
faites sont partagés et les objectifs de
lisibilité et de justice sociale que
vous poursuivez sont légitimes
je crois sincèrement qu une telle
réforme constitue une opportunité unique
de bâtir un système plus juste avec
l'extinction des régimes spéciaux qui
présentait l'inconvénient de lier les
droits un statut ou l'appartenance à une
entreprise et non un parcours
professionnel
je vous le dis avec gravité monsieur le
ministre la méthode choisie par le
gouvernement ne nous permet pas d'avoir
des certitudes sur le fait que nous
atteignons ses objectifs que nous avons
pourtant en partage alors que nous
sortons de débats inachevé en commission
spéciale n'avons aujourd'hui aucune
visibilité sur les contours définitifs
de la réforme que notre assemblée
s'apprête à examiner en costume d'abord
votre méthode et la rapidité par la
vôtre mais vous accorderez que nous
donner deux mois lorsque votre
prédécesseur a disposé de 24 mois il y a
quand même un fossé que je ne comprends
pas
sommes nous prêts à passer quelques
semaines en plus monsieur le ministre
lorsqu'on doit légiférer pour les 50
prochaines années pourquoi s'empresser
de voter cette réforme avant les
élections municipales
j'imagine pas une seconde que les
calculs politiques l'emporterait sur
l'exigence de cohésion sociale qui est
au coeur de cette réforme
le premier enseignement à tirer de
l'échec de la commission spéciale même
si madame la présidente je l' ai dit
l'autre jour où il avait animé avec
talent c'est le fait que nous ne l'avons
pas eu le temps
en décidant d'une procédure accélérée en
nous imposant de tels délais d'examen
le gouvernement ne crée pas les
conditions de la confiance
pourtant à débats parlementaires
approfondis doit avoir lieu pour
éclairer les françaises et les français
et on l'a eue sur le début du texte
pour autant je veux le dire avec force à
certains de nos collègues répondre cher
andré chassaigne à l'affaiblissement du
parlement par son habit doucement à
travers une obstruction parlementaire et
bien paralysera notre insu
sion ça sera une erreur que l'on paiera
collectivement
j'en appelle également un peu plus
d'humilité s'attaquer au système de
retraites eric woerth est là il le dira
c'est pas chose aisée on a dû légiférer
à plusieurs reprises je me souviens de
françois hollande qui n'a pas tenu sa
promesse sur la retraite à 60 ans et
rappelons que c'est un gouvernement
socialiste qui a décidé l'augmentation
de la durée de cotisation à 43 ans
tout cela mes chers collègues ça veut
dire que nos débats doivent être à la
hauteur des attentes
au delà de la précipitation imposé par
le gouvernement
le manque de confiance se traduit par
des incertitudes immenses et des lacunes
évidentes
le recours sans précédent aux
ordonnances j'ai interrogé deux fois le
premier ministre sans réponse vient
priver l'assemblée nationale de débats
sur des pans entiers de ce projet de loi
cela concerne aussi via l'intégration de
certains régimes dans les systèmes
universels celui des marins par exemple
de même que les modalités de convergence
des cotisations pour les fonctionnaires
et les salariés des régimes spéciaux ces
ordonnances monsieur le ministre
et je suis persuadé qu'au fond de vous
même on a quelque chose en partage
nuisent à la lisibilité de la réforme et
mine la confiance en plus quand on
connaît le jugement du conseil d'état et
on sait que l'étude d'impact a été
bâclée sait ce qu'il dit franchement il
ya de quoi avoir de la défiance
l'incompréhension mais aussi du fait des
concessions accordées aux navigants
aérien par exemple et qui conduit le
conseil d'état a parlé d'un système
universel avec cinq régimes différents
qui met en place des règles dérogatoires
plus incompréhensible encore des
négociations toujours en cours entre le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
elles ont lieu en parallèle de nos
travaux en commissions elles continuent
même à l'heure où nous parlons et elles
se prolongeront pour certaines à l'issue
de la promulgation de la loi
autrement dit nous avons sont dans le
noir pour ce qui nous concerne
concernant le financement l'emploi des
seniors la garantie des plantes des
pensions et des salaires des
fonctionnaires
les cotisations des indépendants ou
encore la pénibilité dont certains
syndicats à juste titre demandent
qu'elle soit enfin plus en compte ce
sont les sujets clés pour s'assurer de
l'efficacité et de l'acceptabilité de la
réforme mais nos débats messieurs minet
sont troublés et rendu confus par des
annonces du gouvernement pendant de
travaux certaines annonces sont de
nature à nous rassurer notamment jacques
maire y tient beaucoup comme la
possibilité d'une retraite progressive à
60 ans d'autres ne font que rajouter de
la confusion à la confusion avec sa
fameuse introduction d'un indicateur
inconnus ont fait des recherches en
nature pas trouvé pour savoir comment on
alors valorisée naturellement la valeur
du point
dans un système à points la confiance
repose sur la confiance dans la valeur
du point
or vous la dossier une daudet qui
n'existe pas encore une preuve je crois
d'un préparation on va débattre mes
chers collègues ça a été dit donc je
serai rapide là dessus sur pas loin des
350 milliards d'euros 14 points de pim
et je ne suis pas seul à déplorer pour
juger de la faisabilité financière de ce
projet de loi est d'ailleurs des
collègues de la république en marche
république le rapporteur général du
budget qui dans une lettre envoyée au
premier ministre a posé à se tourner des
questions des questions nombreux
compensations financières pour les
enseignants et chercheurs impact des
prélèvements sur les cotisations sur les
primes des fonctionnaires
conséquence de la baisse de cotisation
de l'état employeur pour l'aligner sur
le régime universel répercussions
naturellement sur les comptes de la
sécurité sociale mesure envoyé à une
conférence des financements dont les
conclusions seront rendues fin avril et
dont l'objectif est de résorber les
familles de 12 milliards de déficit en
compte tenu de l'ampleur du déficit un
ensemble de solutions basées sur un
effort partagé par tous nous paraît plus
efficace plus équitable est susceptible
de recueillir appui large consensus
condition indispensable pour créer la
confiance dans le cas de mise en place
d'un âge pivot des modalités pourraient
être prévues afin qu'ils ne s'appliquent
pas de manière automatique
indifférenciée mais au contraire
monsieur le ministre en prenant compte
des situations particulières comme la
pénibilité
la longueur des carrières les situations
de handicap
le groupe liberté territoire rappelle
son attachement un principe fondamental
l'équilibré du système
oui son équité oui l'effort doit être
proportionnelle aux
capacités de chacun au travers de
dispositifs progressif et redistributif
le ciel mini vous l'aurez compris votre
projet de loi est perfectible
notre groupe appelé le choix d'être
responsable à peine plus de 80
amendements mais je partage l'émotion de
ma collègue jeanine dubié lorsqu'on voit
que nombre d'entre eux ont été déclarées
irrecevables
où est le parlement dans ces conditions
là notre groupe a fait le choix donc
s'il a des critiques à formuler il va
vous faire des propositions et nous
avons déjà fait ses propositions d'abord
la gouvernante pour faire confiance au
paritarisme se garder d'une étatisation
de la démocratie sociale le modèle
agirc-arrco doit nous inspirer
or le respect d'une règle d'or
budgétaire et l'ajustement automatique
des paramètres à l'espérance de vie
contraindront fortement les décisions
l'approbation par décret limitera le
rôle des syndicats c'est pourquoi nous
demandons d'associer le parlement
démocratie parlementaire et démocratie
sociale doivent se compléter
des responsables syndicaux conditionné
l'autre jour l'ont dit eux mêmes afin de
garantir plus de transparence et
s'assurer de la confiance des assurés
dans le système des retraites
des améliorations sont possibles sur les
dispositifs de solidarité
s'agissant du minimum de pension nous
regrettons monsieur le ministre la
double condition d'accès pour en
bénéficier puisqu'il faudra d'une part
respecter une durée l'assurant de 43 ans
et prendre sa retraite à 65 ans le
fameux hd qui libre cette double règles
se fera au détriment des personnes ayant
une carrière longue avec des faibles
revenus
par ailleurs pourquoi attendre 2025 pour
faire passer le smic des routes retraite
des non salariés agricoles de 75 à 85%
du smic alors qu'en moyenne leurs
pensions ne dépasse pas 750 euros en
deçà du seuil de pauvreté
rappelons de plus que le minimum
contributif atteint aujourd'hui 970
euros ce qui relativise grandement la
portée de cette mesure au delà des
agriculteurs et des indépendants
s'agissant des droits familiaux
le dispositif clé du projet de loi
consiste à attribuer pour chaque
naissance d'une majoration de 5 %
et poids qui est une majoration
supplémentaire de 1% à chaque parents
d'au moins trois enfants pour autant
deux dispositifs se complètent
aujourd'hui une majoration des trimestre
dès le premier enfant et une majoration
de pension de 10 % à partir du troisième
enfant nous craignons que ce système
soit défavorable pour les parents de
trois enfants et plus enfin sans vouloir
être exhaustif nous ont pu aller plus
loin en prenant compte des spécificités
des aidants des travailleurs handicapés
qui connaissent un taux d'emploi plus
faibles que le reste de la population
nous attendons davantage concernant le
départ anticipé ou la bonification des
points nous regrettons que certaines
situations soit écarté nous proposons
ainsi l'octroi de points de solidarité
aux sapeurs pompiers volontaires ou aux
responsables associatifs pour valoriser
l'engagement citoyen qui nécessitent
souvent sacrifice de sa carrière donc de
sa retraite
de même pour la prise en compte de la
pénibilité nous sommes favorables à la
mise en place d'accords de branche pour
déterminer l'exposition aux quatre
facteurs de pénibilité
exclu depuis 2017 voyez monsieur
ministre des inquiétudes doivent être
levés et des pistes d'amélioration
nombreux c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous voulons aller au bout du débat
parlementaire
la balle est dorénavant dans votre camp
surtout je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
gravité parce que j'ai déjà connu des 49
3 dans cette maison
ça s'est très mal terminé j'étais à
cette même tribune lorsque le président
de la république était à votre place
et lorsqu'on a fait passer la loi macro
par 49 3 vous avez vu comment tout cela
s'est terminé
il faut prolonger les débats mais celui
du rejet le débat parlementaire
parce qu'on ne peut pas priver la
représentation nationale d'un débat
parce que les français nous regardent
une nous voit et il s'agit de leur
avenir et des 50 prochaines années
je vous demande sur les ordonnances dû
réfléchir je vous demande d'associer les
groupes parlementaires
je vous demande monsieur le ministre de
peser de tout notre poids pour qu'il y
ait un vrai débat car la cohésion
sociale comme l'a très bien fait le
conseil national de la résistance
elle se crée dans la confiance et non la
défiance je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président vigier la
porte à madame clémentine autain pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre votre projet c'est un
enterrement c'est un enterrement de
droit arraché dans les grandes heures de
conquête sociale de notre pays
c'est une liquidation des mécanismes de
solidarité
c'est un tapis rouge que vous faites
pour les fonds de pension privés
c'est une lame de mépris pour la
majorité des français qui s'opposent à
votre nouveau régime c'est un bras
d'honneur fait à tous ces secteurs de la
société qui crient leur colère depuis
plus de deux mois au prix de jour et
deux jours de salaire en moins quand ce
n'est pas un oeil qui est perdu votre
projet c'est une claque aux
parlementaires transformer en paillasson
avec une procédure d'urgence un texte à
29 trou laissé au bon vouloir de
l'exécutif sur les points structurants
de la réforme et sur la base d'une étude
d'impact complètement délirante votre
réforme c'est aussi un pied-de-nez au
conseil d'état qui a jugé sévèrement
votre texte mal ficelé lacunaire sans
visibilité financière
et pourtant et pourtant vous vous
obstinez vous vous obstinez à imposer
une usine à gaz dont tout le monde aura
compris le résultat et le résultat il
est simple c'est un allongement
exponentielle de la durée de cotisation
et une baisse programmée des pensions et
voilà où vous conduit au fond l'univers
des 3%
une règle fait sur un coin de table par
des technocrates transformer en règle
d'or à bruxelles
mettre davantage de richesses en commun
réduire le temps de travail pour
permettre à toutes et tous de pouvoir
partir à 60 ans avec une pension minimum
au smic pour une carrière complète et ne
laisser personne personne en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
vous n'y pensez pas non il faut raboter
il faut raboter il faut faire payer ceux
et plus encore celle qui prime
déjà pendant que le monde de la finance
ce gamme sans entrave et que les hyper
riches en poche
vos réductions fiscales et vous avez
donc imaginé une grande refonte du
système pour passer d'un régime à
prestations définies un régime à
cotisations définies avec vous on saura
ce que l'on cotise mais on ne saura pas
ce que l'on m'a touché ni quand on va le
toucher autant dire que c'est une espèce
de grande loterie une loterie et et vous
ne savez d'ailleurs toujours pas comment
se calculera la valeur du point
c'est dire si votre dogmatisme n'a
d'égal que votre amateurisme parce que
c'est un chemin en commission alors que
nous vous interrogions qui est sorti du
chapeau le revenu d'activité moyen un
indice inconnu de l'insee mais que vous
faites rentrer parmi les paramètres de
calcul de la valeur du point au chausse
pied au dernier moment et même pas
partout dans le texte notamment à la fin
c'est totalement totalement kafkaïen et
dans le chapeau toujours en cours de
route dans la commission alors que les
avocats jettent leurs robes
voici que débarque un abattement fiscal
une compensation imaginé en dernière
minute
n'importe comment et tant pis si on
déshabille la sécurité sociale pour
habiller la hausse drastique des
cotisations retraite des indépendants
mais si vous cherchez des sous monsieur
le ministre pourquoi ne pas faire
rentrer dans l'assiette des cotisations
les revenus du capital
en les alignant simplement sur le régime
général 28%
ce sont 25 6 milliards d'euros que nous
pourrions mettre au pot commun des
retraites mais vous vous avez choisi de
fragiliser plus encore les retraites des
femmes et de tous ceux qui travaillent
durement qui gagne peu qui ont des
carrières précaires h et pénible et ce
sont elles ce sont eux qui paieront
demain
l'addition et quand vous vous adressez à
elle a eu quand vous adresser à nous
vous nous dites qu'au fond cette réforme
leur donnera une liberté de choix mais
de quelle liberté parle et vous monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de
quelle liberté parlez-vous celle de
choisir entre une retraite de misère ou
mourir au travail
en réalité notre liberté la liberté du
grand nombre elle ne rentre pas dans
votre libéralisme économique et
l'égalité elle ne se satisfait
absolument pas de l'équité qui est un
sous produit de l'égalité est ce que
vous organisez au fond c'est une grande
régression une immense régression
sociale et c'est pourquoi puisque nous
revenons en arrière je pense à ces mots
de jean jaurès il a prononcé ici en 1910
de la magnifique idée d'assurance
sociale qui crée pour tous les salariés
pour tous les salariés endroits certains
intangible sans humiliation sans
condition nous retombons à une loi
d'aumône et d'arbitraire ou le bon
plaisir des autorités distribuera
quelques miettes à des pauvres choisit
alors mes chers collègues je vous le dis
face à ce désastre face à cette
destruction de notre régime
on est là on est là et même si vous ne
le voulait pas on est là merci prochaine
séance ce soir 21h30 suite du projet de
loi